hey there fellow townscapers and welcome
back to the channel as always thank you
so much for stopping by is always
greatly appreciated if it's your first
time here i just want to give you a
really really big welcome and i hope you
enjoyed this video today just a couple
of things before we get started let me
just thank everyone that's joined the
channel these past couple of weeks have
been really really crazy i got a huge
influx of views likes and comments and
subscriptions and i just want to thank
you all so much i really really
appreciate it from the bottom of my
heart i really appreciate the love and
support from you guys and i hope you all
continue to stick around and i hope you
enjoy the content that i have to offer i
want to give a big shout out to all of
my most recent contest winners they all
won a free copy of townscaper also not
too long ago i received the first entry
for the paint over contest and it was
really really really good so let's give
a big round of applause to droquis
[Applause]
he entered the paint over contest and
his entry was really really good his
work is really impressive he enters some
photos and i will show you one here and
he also entered a code to add to the
gallery as well if you are on twitch you
can find him there under the name
drawqueeze i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly and i'll put it in the
description i'm really excited because
he's the first entry and it was a very
very good one so shout out to him for
his amazing submission you can see his
full submission photos and the clipboard
code in the gallery on my website go
check him out and show him some love
okay just go see what he's doing the
links will be in the description if you
want to enter the pan over contest the
link will be in the description all you
have to do is watch the video below and
it'll tell you everything that you need
to know it's very simple you do a paint
over you submit the photo if you want to
insert a code so that other people can
check that out on townscaper as well
then you will have the capability of
doing so
so with that being said allow me to
welcome you to townscaper university
this is my official basic tips and
tricks guide i have other videos but
this compiles everything into one once
you are finished with this guide you
will have officially graduated from
townscape university and you will be a
master of townscaperology so let's just
jump right in and get started i also
added some chapters so you can make this
crash course even more crash coursier if
you have to run through it so
let's talk about bases or foundation the
most important thing in townscaper is
your base or platform you cannot build
any structure without a base your base
can be on the grid it can float in the
air or it can be on scaffolding you'll
see what i mean as we go through the
guide so you have the simple cobblestone
base you have the structure or a house
block on scaffolds and then you have the
ever so popular floating base of course
to make a simple cobblestone base you
will just have to point and click and
the base will take the shape of the grid
when you are building your base and you
find yourself in a situation where you
want your blocks to be a specific shape
while building do keep in mind that the
shapes are highlighted no matter the
surface so to generate a simple scaffold
base you just pick a shape you want to
click on the grid and build a tower to
your desired height after you build this
tower you simply remove all blocks from
below the only thing that you should
have left is the top block and scaffolds
will generate as you remove the lower
blocks it's not required to keep your
cobblestone block or your cobblestone
base once you have generated your
scaffolds as they can stand in water
there are a lot of things that you can
do with scaffolds although they aren't
really my favorite aesthetically they
still serve a purpose and they make for
some very interesting builds if your
towers are really really really tall
what you can do is you can use town
shell it's a tool that will allow you to
remove blocks located within certain
levels and once you remove those blocks
and you enter the code into townscaper
you'll see that depending on how many
blocks however many blocks you've
removed from that tower it will be
replaced with scaffolds it's really
really cool but we're going to talk
about township very soon i have a whole
chapter dedicated to townshil
so to make a floating base you want to
find circles or other shapes with
rounded corners here's something really
cool that i want to show you guys i saw
this in a discord from a username dvs
dave his photo here is a really great
example and it really made my brain
explode because i honestly would have
never thought of something like this i
mean just look at this you can see what
kind of amazing shapes that you can make
float he
is really good so
you know this is something to keep in
mind
use your imagination try to see what you
can make float you never know what
you'll come up with so when you're
making your floating bases keep in mind
that you can place them as low as you
want or as high as you want but you have
to make sure that there is at least one
block of space in between the grid and
the platform it's very simple after you
pick your shape you just build to your
desired height if you want your floating
base to be as low as possible of course
you would just place two blocks and
build your shape on the second layer and
remove the bottom block if you want your
floating base to be higher you would
just build a tower within your shape and
then when you get to your desired height
you will fill in that shape and remove
the tower from below at this point your
propeller should generate if you find
yourself in a situation where your base
will not generate propellers you want to
look at your shape on the grid and just
make sure that there are no sharp
corners sometimes the star shape can be
the cause of this you may have to play
with it a little bit but for the most
part it is pretty easy if you have a
full base and you don't want to
disassemble or demolish it to increase
or decrease your height you can always
use town shell once again this tool is
amazing it has plenty of functions that
allow you to edit or manipulate your
builds but we're going to talk about
this a little later
let's talk about stairs stairs are
really easy you can pretty much put
stairs almost anywhere please keep the
word almost in mind to make a simple
staircase on the water you need a 1 by 3
base and two blocks one on each end
leaving the middle and open space this
will generate a very simple staircase
that leads to the ocean if you want to
make your stairs wider it's as simple as
expanding your base remember that stairs
can only be two blocks wide but you can
always make a staircase next to your
existing staircase if you want to make
your stairs taller you would have to of
course expand your base like this
stairs can also come in different shapes
and sizes so you can make slightly
curved around the stairs on circle grids
like this
[Music]
and you can also make stairs on small
corners like this
[Music]
and stairs can also be placed in
archways like this
[Music]
so let's move on to archways and
doorways archways and doorways are
similar in the way that they both
require a wall of a minimum of three
blocks wide to work to build an archway
you need to place a base of three blocks
then you want to build a wall at a
minimum size of two blocks tall you can
also make your archways taller like this
and they can be enclosed to make a door
like this
you can make them wider you just want to
widen your base and add a roof to the
top archways can also be generated in
different shapes like so
to make doorways you want to make a
building from a set of blocks this
building must have a base size at a
minimum of three blocks by two blocks
then you want to add a second and third
layer to your base like this after that
you can make your doorway by removing
the middle block on one of your walls if
you're building a small like this model
the 3x2 block model you can always make
your doorway a small tunnel by removing
the middle block in your doorway like
this if your building has extra walls
behind the door you can make entryways
to your door like so
[Music]
and you can also make tunnels for larger
structures like this
and you can also make your doorways
taller like this
[Music]
you can also make archways or stone
entries to gardens as well but there are
some restrictions for entryways if you
are working with different colors do
keep in mind that all three of those
blots have to be the same color on the
first two layers as long as the three
blocks connected are the same color you
should be good even if the entire wall
of your garden is a different color you
can convert your entryways into archways
but your garden will disappear in order
to prevent this all you have to do is
place a block in front of the archway
you will lose the stone archway but you
will still have your garden and it makes
for really really good aesthetics
so let's move on to roofs roofs are very
easy it's as simple as placing more
blocks on a cobblestone surface when
your structures or buildings get bigger
you will have to manipulate the surface
a little bit from my personal experience
your roof will turn a cobblestone once
your building reaches a size of three
blocks wide
can also happen when making long walls
with structures attached
in order to change the cobblestone back
to roofing or shingles you have to start
from the middle like this
it doesn't matter what end you start
from as long as it's the middle once
your roof has been generated it will be
easy to keep intact keep in mind the
bigger and more complex your building
shapes are the more you will have to
play with the blocks to get the desired
look
[Music]
so let's talk about balconies balconies
are one of my favorite things to do i
need to get in the habit of making more
honestly balconies are really fun
because they look really nice when
generated on a shape other than a square
but they look good on squares as well
they are very easy it's just a matter of
extending a block from your building or
structure like this you can also put
them in front of archways and doorways
like this
my favorite thing to do with them is to
put them on abnormal shapes like this
to make them larger you simply extend
them by adding blocks at the same level
and scaffold will appear to support them
if you want to give it a more fancier
look or you just don't like scaffolds
all you have to do is replace the
scaffolds with blocks and your balcony
will still be supported
[Music]
so let's move to cranes in lighthouses
to make a crane you have to have a base
of three blocks the best way to describe
the next step is to basically make an
archway the minimum height would be a
wall of two layers after you make your
arch way you want to add one block on
top of the archway right in the middle
then you want to remove the two blocks
on each side of the second layer like
this after you want to remove or
demolish your archway by clicking under
the top block like so you can make your
cranes taller but you cannot connect
them directly
you can however separate them by one
block inch and create a row of cranes
and you can connect the supporting walls
as well as remove the base blocks from
the middle
do
lighthouses are very easily done all you
have to do is make a tower and alternate
your colors you can mix any colors they
don't have to stay the same something to
remember is that you cannot use the same
color right after the other or you will
reset the pattern
[Music]
[Music]
the minimum required height is three
blocks tall starting from the grid but
if you are already building on a base
that is larger than one block you will
need to add three blocks from the base
in order to generate a lighthouse
if you want to build lighthouses
connected to structures do remember the
rule of three will still apply so you
would have to add extra blocks to
compensate for the height of the
connected structure
lighthouses can also be placed on cranes
like this
[Music]
walls gardens and garden paths this is
one of my favorite parts of townscaper
walls are simple you just make your base
and build your walls on the second layer
around the perimeter of the base until
they connect and enclose the area when
you do so you will generate a garden one
thing that you may notice while building
is that your garden can disappear if you
remove a block or add an extra block on
a certain spot i'm not certain of all
the blocks or grid spaces that can cause
this effect but what i can tell you is
the main cause could be not placing a
corner block while enclosing a garden or
adding blocks on structures attached to
walls like this
[Music]
depending on where you are on the grid
small stone gates and fences will
generate based on the grid shapes or
patterns
if you want to make garden paths across
your garden it is required to add stone
entries to your walls to make a simple
path across your garden just make an
entry right across from another one keep
in mind the larger the garden the more
complex it becomes so when you play with
it you can find some interesting
pathways along with some what i assume
to be small fountains placed in the
center of some of the garden paths
something else to think about is the
placement of blocks around the garden
paths if they are too close the pass
will disappear so if you want to
maintain your garden pass you just want
to make sure you avoid the very edge of
those paths
so we're moving on to bridges bridges
are fun if you want to separate areas or
provinces for lack of better word or
cities or towns whatever you would like
to call it this would be a great way to
do it of course the easiest way to do it
is to just make one block wide path of
cobblestone in the direction you want to
build your bridge if you want to make
higher or more advanced bridges it's
similar to making stairs but you want to
remove the middle bricks from the bottom
of the structure like this
[Music]
so let's talk about clothes lines and
flags clotheslines and flags are easy to
generate they can generate in between
towers and they can generate in the
middle of archways sometimes they won't
generate depending on the placement of
the blocks on the grid if you look at
this footage here you can see the
difference between the two
[Music]
so
so
let's talk about townshil this program
is really really amazing i talked about
talent show before a few months ago and
i was really impressed by this tool
because it really takes townscaper to a
whole new level the video that i created
is slightly outdated because there was a
recent update so i will go over the
program today briefly so that you can
see what is new but i highly recommend
you going to mogo's channel so that you
can see the full showcase video and
you'll also have access to the download
so this is townshill you can do many
things like change the height of your
builds you can change the colors you can
remove blocks combine builds there are
even preloaded codes that you can use in
order to just get yourself on on the
right path if you're looking for some
inspiration this one right here is my
favorite i just really love the way
it just came out it really does look
like mickey mouse and it makes the
townshill experience even better in my
opinion there's so much more to this
program i'd like that i can't you know
do it justice honestly you have to go to
moko's channel to see it for yourself so
make sure you go show moko j some love
the links will be in the description
below so just some final thoughts i've
had a couple of townscapers ask me if i
had any advice as far as building is
concerned the only advice that i have
for you guys is to take your time and
use your imagination townscaper in my
personal opinion is art it's a digital
canvas that allows you to create
beautiful towns no two towns will ever
be the same and everyone's style is
different you have to play with the grid
and just see what's out there as far as
combos don't be afraid to remove blocks
here and there uh because you never know
what you're gonna get and if you don't
like the way it looks you can just
change it back play with the colors and
you'll notice how connecting blocks may
or may not change just messing around
with the grid in different colors will
give you a new perspective on aesthetics
just experiment with it and get crazy
and just you know just let your
imagination soar you'd be surprised what
you can do with townscaper seriously i
see some really really cool stuff on
discord by the way if you're not in the
discord you should definitely join it
i'm going to put the links back in the
description so if you want to join the
discord and you want to meet like-minded
people who also enjoy townscaper that is
the place for you to be that concludes
this tutorial you have officially
graduated from townscape university and
you can move your tassels to the right
of your cap to signify your rite of
passage in townscape or academia i hope
you guys enjoyed this video please make
sure that you check out the links in the
description below there are some really
amazing people that i talked about moko
j you gotta go check out township you
gotta go check out joaquis
and and go check out his twitch go check
that out just go just go do it you guys
join the discord just go do it i hope
you guys enjoyed this video thank you
all for your support as always it's
greatly appreciated i really really
appreciate it from the bottom of my
heart i hope you guys stick around for
more and i hope you guys continue to
enjoy my content and i will see you all
next time
you